bloom finishes training and is now
released as the biggest open source
language model to date a new chinese
super computer is allegedly able to
compute brain scale ai models
and both ian goodfellow and andre
carpati leave their jobs welcome to ml
news
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone to ml news
brother ml old i've been gone for a
while what happened yeah sorry i was uh
busy getting cancelled and also but you
know i'm back so we're gonna catch up on
everything that happened over the summer
and we're gonna do it in different
installments so if your favorite thing
is not in the news right now maybe wait
a bit or remind me of it this
installment is all about large models
there have been a plethora of huge
models coming out of both companies and
research initiatives speaking of which
big science is a research conglomerate a
workshop a group of people over 1 000
researchers from over 250 countries
coming together and trying to replicate
something like gpt-3 not only replicate
but go beyond bloom is the result of
this effort it is a 176 billion
parameter language model which is
released as fully open source the model
has been developed open source has been
trained open source and is now released
to the world for everyone to use and
research but not only that other than
something like gpt3 we know everything
that's going into these models we know
what data is in there and the data is
really cool the model is explicitly made
to be multilingual in fact the training
data contains over 59 languages probably
even more now 13 of these 59 are
programming languages so the model is
also going to be relatively decent at
that but this is a huge step forward for
open source research for language
research and especially when it comes to
less represented languages in the usual
training data the model was trained with
sponsored compute and is available on
the hugging face hub to download you can
even enter a little prompt over here yet
they do only accept small or short
prompts for now because the model is
rather large
no 54 and 20 is not exactly four but
we'll get there bloom we'll get there
now one interesting aspect about this
model is that it is released under the
big science real license which is the
responsible ai license this license is
kind of like a copy left license in the
sense that if you create derivative
works of this model like if you fine
tune it you have to release it under the
same terms as this license this license
governs the use of the model and
essentially says that you cannot use
this model for a certain number of
things which are listed in the license
so if you look at the license you have
to scroll down a little bit and if you
scroll down more there's like a huge
blank space and then there's appendix a
and these are the use restrictions now
most of these restrictions are fairly
standard for example you are not allowed
to use the model in any way that
violates you know state law
international law federal law and so on
you're not allowed to use the model for
the purpose of exploiting harming or
attempt to exploit or harm minors in any
way there's a number of these things the
more interesting ones which i think are
you're not allowed to use the model for
fully automated decision making that
adversely impacts an individual's legal
rights or otherwise creates or modifies
a binding enforceable obligation so a
binding enforceable obligation will be
something like a contract so you are not
allowed to use this model to make
automatic contract decisions i'm not
entirely sure what exactly that
prohibits let's say the authors here
intended to prevent something like
automated decision making in terms of
hiring someone or maybe automated
selling of something like insurance like
a person comes i want to get some
insurance and they just talk to a
chatbot and the chatbot you know
actually makes the contract i'm not
exactly sure how this license would
apply here like could i make it such
that the chatbot simply makes a
suggestion back to the human says like
here is an offer you know you can accept
it or not or does at any point need to
be a human in the loop from the side of
the model like for sure the model can
make a contract offer about a piece of
insurance but then maybe an insurance
agent will still have to look over that
look over the applicant and say yeah
that's correct or that's not correct i
think this is going to be
hashed out at some point which is not
now this is probably not the first time
software is released under such
restrictions but probably the first time
a big ai model is the other interesting
one is you're not allowed to generate or
disseminate information or content in
any context for example posts articles
tweets chatbots or other kinds of
automated bots without expressly and
intelligibly disclaiming that the text
is machine generated but who would do
something like this i mean come on all
in all i think the license is actually
fairly permissible there's a lot of
things that you actually can do with a
model like this and that's really cool
and it's available for everyone to
research and even build monetizable
products on top of it so let me know
what you think in the comments about the
model about the licenses and so on
other big models yam 100b as a 100
billion parameter gpt like language
model by yandex and it can mainly speak
english and russian now if we go not one
but three orders of magnitude bigger in
terms of models south china morning post
writes china's super computer achieves
global first with brain scale ai model
so this apparently and i'm going to say
apparently because apparently there are
no official statements out yet there is
a new supercomputer in china that has
trained a neural network with 174
trillion parameters that's trillion that
is a thousand times bigger than
something like gpt3 or bloom or any of
these biggest models that we have today
now we've seen trillion parameter models
before but they've usually been sparse
in some way and we have no clue over
what this model here represents but as
the article says this does approach the
number of synapses in a brain now that's
not to say that we've replicated the
brain but these models are getting
extremely huge so apparently the
scientists said that they had achieved a
decent performance from the
unprecedented brain scale ai model
whatever that means they also say the
communication between the nodes of the
supercomputer is over 23 petabytes per
second with one researcher saying that
the machine's parallel computing ability
mimicked human thinking like eating
while watching television i have to say
in in all these stages of building agi
certainly the last step is going to be
an ai that can eat while watching
television i have the feeling there is
hardly a greater human achievement than
doing those two things at the same time
in fact it's true i've never ever seen a
robot or a piece of software that can
eat while watching television so if this
is true agi is almost solved
meta ai releases a blog post along with
a paper under the heading no language
left behind another huge language model
in fact a translation model that focuses
on translating between a plethora in
fact over 200 languages and with a
particular focus on low resource
languages low resource languages have
been a problematic topic for machine
translation for a while because ai
models especially big models that
perform really well need lots of data in
the question of machine translation they
in fact need aligned data they need the
same text in two different languages to
be able to translate between those
languages there are techniques like
pivoting but that still requires you to
have like parallel data from both
languages to english at some point this
model overcomes this by in fact using
another ai model to automatically align
texts of different images so you can
feed in unaligned text and the model
will find parts in each of the text that
probably align with each other this then
serves as a base state to set to train a
translation system this is really cool
and we've seen this a number of times to
in fact use one model to generate
training data for another model and i
strongly believe that we might go beyond
this paradigm this really simple
paradigm of you know get big data train
one model and done we've seen a number
of configurations for example with
generative model we've seen various
benefits of having a critic a model that
selects and ranks the outputs of
generative models in order to make it
better and in the case with this model
right here and others we've seen
numerous models where first training
data is automatically generated by
another model and i think this opens up
a possibility if you think of this if
you think not just what can i do with
one model how can i train one model but
think about the models that we already
have and think about what you could do
to use them to create training data to
train other models that we usually
wouldn't have enough training data for
this has been thought about obviously
for a long time i think a lot of people
when they learned about gans for the
first time they were like wow we can
create so much training data to train
our classifiers but this is kind of the
wrong way around a generative model like
again has much more information
contained in it than an image classifier
which kind of reduces the space to the
number of classes so it seems like you
kind of have to go from models that know
less to models that know more what
exactly that entails i think you know
smart people will have to come up with
things like this but it's really cool to
think about and this is a really cool
work so check it out
all right i quickly wanted to mention
this workshop here which is held on july
28th so potentially kind of right now or
something like this depending on when
this is released this is a workshop on
the leakage and reproducibility crisis
in ml based science machine learning
itself obviously has a reproducibility
problem but there are also a number of
machine learning based papers in other
fields such as medicine chemistry
physics biology and whatnot and these
are apparently even worse in terms of
reproducibility when they apply machine
learning so this is a workshop focusing
on this various pitfalls like no train
test split temporal leakage and things
like pre-processing on train and test
sets together now i have to admit i'm
guilty of this i've done this before but
if you're interested in topics like this
and want to learn more this workshop is
surely a good place to go
techcrunchwrites openai arrival ai21
labs raises 64 million dollars to ramp
up its ai powered language services yet
another startup raising giant amounts of
money to build giant models i'm not
exactly sure all this money flowing into
this stuff is going to pay off for all
of them i mean surely not for all of
them is it gonna pay off for
a lot of them i don't know but i've
reported on ai 21 in the past and i
think they have a really interesting
approach with their jurassic x models
where they try to compose different
tools and make the language model not
solve tasks as such but make the
language model learn how to use other
programs other tools in order to
complete its task i think that's a you
know a really cool paradigm to go about
things i'm not sure how it's going to
work out for them business-wise but i
congratulate them on their funding round
exciting times
ian goodfellow is leaving apple to join
deepmind has long been rumored articles
have been written that he's not happy
with the remote working agreements and
so on but he's released a simple tweet
and as always take what is rumored by
journalists with a grain of salt usually
you know only about five percent of the
story of what's going on in any case uh
i wish ian the best of success at
deepmind seems like cool times for him
and very similarly andre carpati is
leaving tesla he's just recently gone on
a sabbatical and now he's leaving for
sure he does not have a place that he's
switching to it seems like he's gonna
focus on doing things he enjoys and you
know good for andre in related news
business insider writes tesla reportedly
reportedly again laid off about 200
workers in its autopilot division very
dark rumors actually say that they all
are replaced by optimus spots but that's
unconfirmed for now
and the last thing right here this is
wer dolly this is a hugging face space
that composes the concept of the popular
game wordle with dali so you get a bunch
of images from dolly mini which is now
crayon and you're supposed to guess the
prompt so this one every time you
refresh you get a new one this one i'm
going to take a guess it is eminem in
gta eminem
[Music]
yeah okay this first try first try but
you know it gets harder promise all
right this was it for ml news slash old
slash what happened over the summer
slash i'm no longer cancelled i hope you
enjoy leave a comment leave a like share
it out subscribe all that stuff please
keep hydrated during these warm times
and i'll see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]
you